oh god it's so hard oh I'm gonna start
sweating it's gonna be ridiculous I
gotta take my pants off you guys can't
see this right probably ah [ __ ] I'm not
wearing underwear right now that
emergency is taken over let's get back
to the vlog so hello hi I'm markiplier
but you knew that but maybe you didn't
because you didn't see me yesterday I
took a day off which is something that I
don't often do in fact I can't remember
the last time that I did think that that
is so in case you've forgotten me my
name is Mark and I do YouTube videos
online the reason I took a day off and
this is something that I very rarely do
but the reason is probably obvious I was
losing sleep I had too much work piling
up I was getting behind on videos I was
waking up at 5:30 every day to get
videos done for an 8:00 a.m. release so
you can imagine that as time goes on
when you're going to bed at like 11:00
and midnight and you're getting up at
5:30 play military schedule it's not
good for you and you're gonna die
eventually and probably a heart failure
in gray hairs you're gonna sprout all
over my face cuz I'm old I'm desperately
trying to hold on about you being 27
years old is really getting to me I'm
already over the hill to you young
Millennials it may not seem that old but
when you get up to my age as old so
anyway I really am grateful that you
guys were so understanding with me
taking a day off I do appreciate that I
don't do it often and I don't like to do
it often because I love to work it's
weird I like working especially because
the work that I do is so fun but the
main reason is yesterday I had to work
on this script and it's been staring at
me in the face for so long and like
Sunday was the deadline I had to get it
done I had to dedicate like six hours
just to writing and I got it done it's
totally cool and what else I managed to
do was I managed to catch up on
recording videos so that you guys can
have enough content on a regular basis
and I don't have to keep scrambling to
record in the morning and then edit in
the morning and then do everything else
in the morning and then fall asleep and
pass out
or p.m. wake up drink myself to death
anyway I'm fine and everything is good
now I got the script done it's for that
this project I've been hinting at for
ever and ever and ever
there's a lot of cool things going on
with it it should be happening very soon
but it's finally done and now I can
focus on the more important things in my
channel which is the stuff that I really
care about and I'm really grateful that
you guys are so understanding in times
like this where I am unfortunately just
I'm one guy I'm one guy I'm editing my
own stuff again I'm just doing
everything by myself so it's very hard
for me as a one-man army with so many
different things to tackle to do it all
by myself
but I'm grateful for to do it but I'm
human I have human limbs
I have human needs I'm a noble man so
just thank you everybody so much for
being so understanding and I have
another question that's gonna sound
really conceited and it's another
example of it'll get rid of all the hood
because youth so desperately is whether
I should dye my hair back red because
I've got enough of my natural black
coming out that I could possibly read I
it again and I could keep the red going
because it's kind of weird with how much
faded it is and and strewn out for my
natural hair color so I didn't want to
get you guys as opinion because the red
is really nice I love the red don't get
me wrong I love the red I want to keep
the red even though I'm staining every
close article that I have with red and
all my channels are spewed with red as
if I murdered 10 million people in my
house which I didn't but I just wanted
to get you guys opinion and here's the
reasons why it's a dilemma I don't mind
keeping the red I really go but it's a
weird thing because now I've reached
this weird point whereby I'm being like
offered roles in other things outside of
YouTube I don't know if I want to
dedicate my time to that but a lot of
things that they request is that I dye
my hair back to a normal color because
colored hair in acting is a very
specific stereotype and you get
stereotyped a lot and real acting it's
like if your character is colored hair
use a certain type of person
and he does this thing in this way
whereas here on YouTube I get to be me
and my inclination is just to follow
what I like and follow what I want
because YouTube has always been about
what I do so that's why I want to get
your opinion on it because you're just
as much a part of this channel as I am
so what do you guys think do you think I
should go for read again or not also a
dawns on me that this video is probably
going to be late so I apologize for that
yesterday was not for nothing this was
for a reason I was just working out this
morning because I've been trying to be
healthy all year and I've been doing a
great job as you can see I've been
getting some sweet results Wow but
enough about that enough about the
silliness the main reason that I wanted
to make this vlog today was because I've
been trying to get involved more in the
community I'm trying to keep up with
everything because there's so many
people now that it's hard to stay in
touch with all the different social
media platforms and it's hard to follow
along for everything so I've been trying
to make it better like effort of doing
that and one of the common things that
I've seen obviously and this is like the
pervasive topic throughout the entirety
of the Internet is hate on the internet
and what hate means and how you deal
with Hayden what he represents when it's
coming at you on the Internet and a lot
of people ask me like how I deal with a
considering I am like the lightning
conduit of hate on the Internet and I'm
totally fine with that I don't mind it
at all because when I started on YouTube
obviously when my first video it went
like viral on Reddit it got like number
three of the amnesia reaction
compilation got like number three on the
video section of Reddit and it was like
the tenth video I ever made and so that
was my first exposure to like a wide
audience and suddenly I was getting so
many subscribers and it was great it was
like my channel is just exploding
there's like tens of subscribers but my
channel is exploding in my eyes and it
was so amazing but then at the same
came in the first influx of hate and I
never experienced internet hate before
in my life and what was weird is that at
first I was like oh they don't know me
oh no I got a convention that I'm cool
so I was like I would like message
people directly being like hey um you're
entitled to your own opinion but I just
wanna let you know I'm cool guy and
obviously that didn't get the response I
warned did it just mean that I gave them
more ammo with which to throw back at me
and that like crafted my philosophy on
how I deal with hate on the Internet and
most of it is just you got to ignore the
majority of it because the majority of
it is just mindless hate coming from
nowhere from people trying to poke bears
wherever they can poke and they give joy
out of getting a response and that's
fine that's the Internet that's life but
when that comes at you a lot of people
don't know how to deal with it because
like you guys are good natured people
most people are good natured people and
it's weird that someone would randomly
want to throw hate at you so the natural
inclination is to try to fix the problem
which is an admirable response
I don't diminish that response in any
way but as far as my advice goes if you
do that if you don't doesn't matter it's
whatever you choose to do but my mindset
when I approach hate is these people the
anonymous hate on the Internet they
don't know who you are as a person they
don't know the experiences that you have
been through individually they don't
know what you've gone through they don't
know the pain of your life they don't
know the joys of your life they know
next to nothing except what you have put
which is a narrow sliver of your life on
the internet so that narrow image is all
they based their hate on and therefore
they don't actually know you and
therefore they don't have any right to
hate on you your life isn't influenced
by that at all because they don't
understand who you are now if this was
coming from a friend if I got a friend
of mine
that came up to me and told me I was a
horrible person and I was just being
awful and what I was doing was wrong and
I should just give up and go home and
not do it ever again that would affect
me like that would affect me because my
friends and the people that I keep in my
life are people that I trust very much
so and that trust means that I trust
their opinion put anonymous people on
the Internet fuck'em who gives a [ __ ]
they're nobody exactly nobody especially
if they're anonymous
now I'm not diminishing Internet friends
at all you can have Internet friends and
people that you trust on the Internet
and you would value their opinion just
as much as anything else but when it
comes to the random spewing toxic venom
that people are thrown around I couldn't
give a [ __ ] about that it means nothing
because I make my videos for anyone that
wants to make my videos I do my things
for anyone that wants to I don't make it
for them they are allowed to not like my
videos they are allowed to take that and
keep it with themselves because I
honestly am okay with them not liking my
videos I'm honestly okay with them not
enjoying what I put in front of them
because that's the narrow sliver that
they see and if they disagree with that
narrow sliver that's totally fine I am a
hundred percent okay with that they can
do whatever they want
like seriously they're their own person
even though they may seem from an
anonymous perspective that they're just
a random somebody but they're random
whoever it really doesn't matter so
they're allowed to take whatever small
view that they have of you and I'm not
saying they're narrow-minded a lot of
them are but and I'm not saying they are
I'm saying they only see a part of you
so you can either try to show them all
of you and most likely they won't listen
but you can either try to show them all
of you or you can try to keep putting
out the best of you possible and that
best of you is the best that you can
possibly make the best that you can
possibly do right now that is the best
you're doing and you do that every day
and events
you'll start to find people that do
enjoy that sliver of who you are and
when they enjoy that then they want to
know more and then they open themselves
up and you opened yourself up to them
and it's just kind of like I don't know
that's how friends are made that's how
people get to know each other that's how
people really make bonds is that they
see things that they agree with and
hopefully doesn't turn into a big circle
jerk but they see things that they agree
with and they're like okay maybe I can
trust this guy maybe I can see what this
girl is all about maybe I can see what
they're creating I kind of like it and
that's like this started something
beautiful and that's the philosophy that
I've taken through for my channel so
that's pretty much all I wanted to talk
about I got rambley again as I always do
but hopefully that made sense to some of
you as far as it comes to hate on the
Internet and I know I'm not an advice
guy but that's just my experience within
how I've dealt with it
over the years so take that for what you
will I hope that helps somebody out
there and thank you everybody so much
for watching I think I covered about
everything this Friday we'll be doing oh
no this Saturday will be doing the
charity livestream I won't be going back
to Cincinnati and joining Wade for a fun
time for charity so remember raves
suggestions for the charity down the
comments below I'm going to be reading
from the last vlog as well and picking
that I'll try to get my pick for
tomorrow so write literally whatever
charity you want get a highly rated
highly reputable charity and let me know
what you want us to raise my for so
thank you again everybody so much for
watching and also write suggestions for
challenges that we can do in the live
stream as well no more painful the
better because I want to see ways upper
oh I'm so malicious like that but thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
you